monsieur grigorian bonjour juste une
question tout simplement
quel est votre regard sur les relations
actuelles entre la france la russie
bonjour d'abord pour pour l'invitation
pour cette discussion savez ça fait
plusieurs années que je suis en russie
et je représente le groupe in fi non
seulement dans la russie en ukraine et
depuis 2002 que je suis là je constate
une évolution très forte des relations
franco franco russe malgré les
difficultés que nous avons connues
malgré les crises que nous avons connues
là on nous sommes à un moment où les
relations franco russes commencent à mon
avis se réchauffer ça a commencé donc en
août dernier nous avons constaté à
partir de moscou que il ya une volonté
appareils dont le dialogue avec avec
avec moscou ça a commencé avec la visite
du président poutine après le discours
de monsieur croc devant les ambassadeurs
après il ya eu un événement tragique
c'est la mort de monsieur chirac et
monsieur poutine fait le déplacement
c'est un symbole très important qu'on
note
après il ya eu le format normandie donc
monsieur peut-il un produit d'été a donc
en france tout tout ça ça parle d'une
certaine dynamique qui commence à être
redynamisé soulet et c'est très positif
le business en france commence à
regarder donc la russie peut être avec
un autre regard
nous avons aussi constaté la volonté
monsieur le bournot le maire de faire
n'est pas dans le censeur d'amélioration
du business franco franco russe et tout
ça est positif en espérant tout
simplement que ça dure parce que nous
sommes entrés dans une année importante
sur le plan de mort est elle aussi en
fins et 2020 je pense que c'est
l'occasion aussi de marquer encore une
fois la présence de la france à côté de
la russie notamment pour démontrer
encore une fois que la russie et la
france ensemble ont joué un rôle
important dans la libération de l'europe
de 2d nazisme tout simplement quoi et le
fait que monsieur un con il a confirmé
sa présence pendant le jour de 9 mai
donc à moscou à mon avis sa marque sa
marque les esprits
nous sommes très contents vous ai parlé
tout de suite de dynamiser les échanges
entre la france à leur fille selon vous
quelles qu'elles peuvent être sous
quelle forme on peut dynamiser ces
échanges quelles sont les clés qui
peuvent permettre c'est au développement
de ces échanges
regardez je suis ici nous sommes à
l'université si le forum et da ros a vu
que je fais j'ai besoin de faire une
petite intervention devant les étudiants
pour parler de du monde de l'éducation
des échanges entre les universités
ça c'est un exemple concret par exemple
que l'on pourrait redynamiser les
relations entre la france et puis la
russie s'est il ya un potentiel énorme
je peux le dire parce que je suis en
très bonne position pour légitime
quelque part pour juger les uns comme
les autres
je suis originaire de l'ex union
soviétique donc en tant que comédien
d'origine je peux être très objectif est
très impartial il avait des français que
j'adore les russes que j'adore et je
peux regarder je constate qu'il ya un
fort potentiel qui malheureusement n'est
pas toujours exploiter correctement le
mot exploités je sais que certains
pourraient dire que c'est un peu
capitaliste mais je parle positivement
d'exploitation des capitales je constate
que en russie il ya un engouement très
fort pour la france enfin les grands
auteurs d'écrits en français c'est
formidable quand quand j'étais jeune je
lisais je regardais les films français
feront à tous cet amour en fait
comporter pour la france et est en
france je constate qu'il ya une couche
de population aussi qui a un regard très
positif sur la russie et d'ailleurs on
continue de lire de parler de dossiers
ce qui est des t-shirts rohff et
d'autres écrivains bronze de tolstoï
donc tout ça ce sont des conditions des
prêts conditions pour regarder le monde
dont près positivement je pense que on
peut toujours faire qu'on peut toujours
trouver les arguments pour ne pas venir
ont aussi pour ne pas travailler en
russie où avec les russes mais si on
regarde calmement dans le monde nous
envie
le changement qu'on connaît les
paradigmes qui change le monde qui
devient multipolaire ne pas avoir de
bonnes relations avec la russie ça
serait une erreur ça c'est un avis qui
n'engage que moi je génère bien que que
mes collègues ou nos partenaires en
france écoute et je peux dire ça en tant
que commerçant conseillers du commerce
extérieur de france et en même temps
membre du conseil d'administration de la
chambre
franco-russe ici à moscou que j'occupe
ccc post en parallèle je constate donc
nous pouvons faire beaucoup plus que
nous faisons il suffit d'avoir la bonne
volonté il suffit d'avoir les bons
partenaires
il suffit de trouver ensemble ensemble
je précise a vécu les bons projets et
c'est autour de ça qu'on peut construire
les bonnes relations avec la france et
la russie
monsieur noyau merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
[Musique]